i mean does it take some brass balls to
do this does it take a certain
percentage of a curious mind like
those sit-downs where you when you walk
in that room
how intense are they how much balls do
you have to have to just like hey have a
seat buddy we're gonna have a little
talk how do you know they're not gonna
pull out a weapon how do you know like
that your life's not in danger it's a
good question talk about that it's
we bullet proof it as much as possible
right and as the years have gone by
we have trended more closely to working
with law enforcement remember the first
two we did we just went out and did i
had security ronnie knight was there was
a you know nbc security guy and former
nypd lieutenant
and so we felt pretty safe but we didn't
have all the background guys as we
progressed
and collaborated with law enforcement
starting in the third investigation
it made it safer
we were able to find out more about this
guy does he carry
a pistol does he have a permit to carry
a pistol for instance in fairfield when
the guy showed up he had a gun in his
car
duct tape rope he was on the list to
become a cop he worked for the cable
company
we knew that there was a possibility he
had a gun with him because we could do
that kind of extensive background when
he approached the house
our internal security coached the decoy
and saying turn around i'm worried about
a gun we had a mass shooting here at a
school lift up your shirt as best as we
could and with some other technology
we determined that he probably didn't
have a gun with him so we'd let him come
in if we think he's carrying the police
will arrest him before he comes in we
don't need a live gun in that confined
space it's not safe
but to your point the first time i
confronted one of these guys yeah my
heart was in my throat
you still get
a little bit anxious you're very focused
guys put their hands in their pockets
that makes you nervous put them on the
table but you control the environment as
much as possible and i've done it enough
times you know we're getting close to
500 guys now
where i can kind of see the way this is
going but you can never take it for
granted
you know we have a lot of protections in
place that we don't show because we
don't want to give those away
and obviously the worst case scenario is
that somebody comes in
tries to do something to get attention
or create harm to themselves or others
and then our security team has to take
action and ends badly for everybody
involved
we have taken the right steps i think
thus far to prevent that from ever
happening and we continue to tweak that
as we go along
yeah you're always on you're always on
edge when you're doing it that's that's
what that's what makes it what it is
right
if it was easy everybody could do it
those scenes where they walk in that
room and it is that is
built for tv
well we're taking people into the
commission of a felony they see the
transcripts they see the text they see
what has been said they see the
motivation and then here he comes
and more often than not they
talk to me
does your job ever make you feel a
certain level of pessimism it seems like
you said the first what two days you had
17 guys then you find out about peter
nygard and it just seems like every time
it gets a little bit worse and it's got
to be it's got to affect your outlook on
life you know
occasionally i get asked that question
and i'm a pretty optimistic guy actually
you know i i do
have a dim view of some aspects of life
but i guess i've gotten to the point
where
you know i know that there's more good
than bad out there and so i don't i try
not to dwell on it i mean and i'm able
to compartmentalize it i mean i think
when you do something for 40 years you
either let it own you
or you put it in its proper perspective
you know
i have i always had balance in my life i
don't know that you can achieve all this
and do everything i've done and have
balance but i have balance now
you know i'm at a great point in my
career where i can do a lot of different
things you know and i do and it's very
satisfying but i don't dwell in it i i i
i escape it i know when to turn it off i
you know i built a day into this trip to
come see you guys by being in the sun
yesterday and relaxing you got a good
time i feel good yeah you got a real
nice time yeah now you know
as we're going through this the reason
why i'm asking about the investigative
journal did there's a lot of things i
would want to hire
a professional to go investigate
like if you look at what's going on
today in the world what would i love to
investigate what what what are tens of
millions of people if not billions of
people what is billions of people in the
last 24 months what would they love to
investigate
i think it's only one thing people would
love to investigate the last 24 months
where the hell did this coronavirus
thing come from
what did they do
what happened could we have prevented it
thank god it wasn't as bad as uh
something else could have been if it was
more deadlier
we lost many lives but it could have
been 50 million it could have been 100
million it could have been a lot more
people than than it cost so isn't it
worth us going and investigating that
and if we do what approach do you take
how do you go about it when it's
international what is the right way to
do it
are they really going to want to
cooperate do you get people from the
inside to be whistleblowers how do you
protect the whistleblowers to come out
and you know share information because
one of the things that is working out
very well with james o'keefe's model is
now people are calling him who are with
new york times who are in those meetings
who are with
you know the cnns or you know the
foxes or the aoans or whatever networks
it is that they call them cbs's abcs
they're calling him and they're saying
listen here's what happened here they
don't want to share this story because
of xyz here's how they protected this
guy here's how they this and he's
getting google facebook that's pretty
what he's doing
so all i'm saying is i think there is a
business model
and uh you know although what catching a
child predator as a parent i'd love for
that show to be on every day because i
think what sometimes you have these
shows like america's most wanted or what
was it bad boys bad boys is that
american cops
that was in the 90s you see these things
and some people would say well you know
to catch predator aren't you training
them to even be wiser on what not to do
or are you putting the fear on this and
cops aren't training people how to
commit crime it's an america's most one
is more of a weight training people i
think it potentially is scaring the hell
out of the guys who say you know i want
to be a little bit more careful i think
the most important thing is
you know when you create an awareness
and a dialogue that didn't exist before
you are achieving your goal so anybody
can say anything about you know you
write a book on financial fraud you know
are you teaching
the next people to
you know mix different kinds of
securities in a toxic soup that creates
the downfall of 2008 no we're teaching
people to avoid getting into that once
again
and it's the same thing in crime
reporting well that was crime reporting
too actually criminal the way this
worked but you know it's it's about
creating awareness and a dialogue and
people are smart enough to make their
own decisions but we're not you know
we're not teaching predators how to pray
on kids
and we're showing how it's done
but i don't think there's ever been a
case where somebody said oh i sought to
get your predator and chris hanson
verbally lambasted this guy so i'm going
to go do it now and be smarter and
better
is there a show like that on on tv like
network like regular cable tv where
people can watch on a weekly basis what
on the predator yeah no we're shooting
them now we're out doing new ones who
are you gonna who you going it's gonna
it's gonna be on trueblue the new uh
digital crime network that we're
starting and launching in november oh
but it's not like abc or abc maybe we're
in discussions we're in discussions
about that too i think these are two
different levels whatever is going to be
to the most to right and you got a
youtube channel as well with a few
hundred thousand subs and you you're
you're you've created content on that if
you enjoyed this short clip click over
here to watch another short clip and if
you want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]